alors on va enquêter comme un petit peu
sur sur vous sur votre vie d'accord vous
êtes très jeune on va faire une
interview première fois via le premier
mensonge auto quoi par exemple je sais
pas et comme les mères d'élèves de la
maternelle très venteuses façon utile je
serai hélène je viendrai chercher tout
de suite thierry lhermitte votre premier
choc ya pas très longtemps
oui on a trop parlé alors non votre
première baffe
c'était avec mon papa tu t'es petit il
voulait dormir il était fatigué c'est un
dimanche après midi
moi j'étais très nerveuse je découvrais
dans tous les sens j'étais avec mon
petit magnétophone et je fais c'est
peut-être un petit peu de bruit c'était
peut-être la goutte qui a fait déborder
le vase j'en suis prêt
et pourtant on ne vous ne voulez pas
vous invitez toujours chez lui oui votre
première idole
le stage là ils ont besoin de se sentir
aimé désiré un merci votre premier
baiser sans la langue la maternelle ah
ouais mais je n'avais pas de chance
parce que j'étais amoureuse d'un garçon
qui ne trouvaient pas joli non plus du
copain parti vert à part c'était une
tournante
donc ça c'était sans la langue à votre
premier baiser avec la lande
13 ans hall lol alors ça c'est fait le à
minuit le lendemain matin dix ans est
définie ouais c'est dégueulasse
quel briseuse de coeur la première fois
tout seul non c'est une question je veux
dire la vérité pas cette question je
n'avais pas pensé et j'ai reçu non mais
c'est vrai j'ai reçu un email d'un mec
qui me dit quand tu fais l'interview
première fois tu te demandes toujours la
première fois de la première fois à 3
pourquoi tu demande pas la première fois
tout seul vous en souvenez pas jamais
tout seul
ah bon la première fois deux jeunes
femmes âgées de green bay moment avant
de la patiente maman oulala c'est que
j'ai deux filles la seule main qui a dit
ce que j'attends ce soir maintenant on
innove d'aller vous coucher première
fois à troyes ah bon ça vous intéresse
pas c'est pas trio du tout du tout à 4
non plus donc j'arrête les éléments les
chiffres pairs s'est calé simon cardon
premier chagrin d'amour à 15 ans déjà
vous étouffer ou à l'âge de 15 ans et
c'était la première fois que je tombais
amoureuse première fois que je me donner
à quelqu'un souffert d'un mois j'étais
folle amoureuse lui même et pas du tout
pourra donc c'était juste pour tirer son
coup comme on peut dire vulgairement
donc j'en étais malade après c'est là
que j'ai commencé à boire
la première cuite secor première cuite
màj j'ai eu une première équipe c'est ce
soir jamais vous n'êtes jamais d'accord
inverse de ses biens pour les pétards
non c'est en faisant part dans cette
saison oui oui ça parce que votre mère
regard non non non c'est vrai c'est dit
hervé bourges qui regarde tu veux
quelque chose que j'aime pas comment vos
émissions vous poser la question sur le
cabanis d'accord hervé première
cigarette 14 ans ouais premier valium
pas encore bravo je félicite le patron
draps
dans tout ça c'est un ring